yeah so please give them
yeah hi everyone also I'm really sorry
for being late I just heard I'm the
reason that um everything's delayed
because I took too long scooting with
the e-scooter over like the bridge and
like looking at hybrid back on the way
because it's my first time in Heidelberg
and interestingly it the city still
always had a very special place in my
heart because it's where my parents met
back in the 80s I think when my mom was
studying Spanish at the University of
Heidelberg and my dad learned like went
to Hotel school so
um yeah it's always without Heidelberg
yeah exactly I would without Heidelberg
I wouldn't exist so it's definitely a
very special pie data and I've always
wanted to visit so I'm really happy to
be here and
um yeah so I will talk about large
language models which is a topic on
everyone's mind and maybe
um is this working
ah the quick intro
um some of you might know me for my work
on Spacey which is an open source
library for natural language processing
in Python
um we've been yeah very lucky to have a
lot of
um users and we have been around for a
long time people seem to have liked the
library it's been downloaded over 160
million times and it's basically focuses
on real world use cases and building
pipelines that can be used in production
and it was designed like that from
pretty much day one and we've put
actually put a lot of work maybe some
people might say too much work in really
ensuring stability not breaking
backwards compatibility but a really
nice effect of that is that there's a
lot of Spacey code out there it hasn't
the actual usage hasn't changed that
much and that means that chat gbt is
actually really good at writing Spacey
code which is kind of like another meter
level like instead of using
to do things for you you could use
chatgpt to generate rules that let
Spacey do something for you much faster
and more efficiently so that's that's
all really cool and another thing we do
at explosion is Prodigy which is a
modern annotation tool that's fully
scriptable in Python and really helps
developers create training data create
evaluation data for machine learning
models especially for any structure task
which is incredibly common in real world
applications and yeah Prodigy is also
um been quite popular we've had we have
we currently have over 8 000 users
um probably
um even more and
um yeah it's also similar to Spacey it's
also really designed from the ground up
to be used in real projects and also be
used as a tool that fits neatly into
your workflow powered by python which
makes it really easy to extend
um any library and currently we and we
have been working on an extension that
takes Prodigy into the cloud together
with Spacey while also ensuring data
privacy scriptability that's currently
in beta
um if that's something you're interested
in like creating data working with data
really going end-to-end from an idea to
a trained model you can also talk to me
about that because yeah we're ready to
roll out our first big product soon and
um yeah yeah oh yeah we can see some of
the Python that goes into Prodigy and
um yeah with all that in mind before we
kind of go deeper into you know large
language models what can they do what
does it all mean
um I think this is a to me this is a
really important distinction that we
kind of need to you know make clear from
the get-go and that's the difference
between generative and predictive tasks
so large language models GPT whatever
these models have introduced like a lot
of new capabilities especially on the
generative side which is stuff like
summarization reasoning problem solving
paraphrasing style transfer question
answering and these are all really cool
and super important and also things that
are things we couldn't so easily do on
that level before and then on the other
hand there are also tasks that where the
output is not text to text but where the
output is more something that's machine
readable instead of human readable and
that's what I call predictive tasks and
that stuff like text classification
entity recognition relation extraction
core reference better solution grammar
morphology semantic parsing discourse
structure everything where the output is
some kind of structured format and I
don't have any exact statistics on that
but I would say that the absolute
majority of all machine Learning Systems
NLP systems that are currently in use
and especially already providing value
are more on the predictive side because
it's often you know often the output
needs to be consumed by something else
feeds into some other process and this
is also an area where you know larger
models can help a lot and they're
surprisingly good at it but also
um not you know not as good yet as you
might think from maybe you know
scrolling through your LinkedIn feed or
talking to chat GPT so there's also
still you know a lot of room for
improvement and I also want to talk
about
um you know kind of a vision that goes
beyond like hey let's just you know talk
to some bot because I we think that hey
that's not ambitious enough you know we
can we can do so much we can go further
than that but basically generative and
predictive that's the distinction and
also of course a lot of the software
we've been working on it's really more
on the predictive side because there's a
lot of really interesting
um stuff you can do there
so
um yep the distinction again human
readable machine readable and
if we're looking at um you know what
like what can these new models that we
all have access to and that have these
new capabilities like what does it mean
for the future how does it all fit in
and what will it say about like our life
and our work in say five to ten years
one thing I always like to do is kind of
go back and look at the history of how
people thought about technology of the
future
um and exact cases where we know the
answer and maybe what we can learn from
that and how we can use that to shape
how we are thinking about the future and
my absolute favorite that I've already
showed I think in many talks so sorry if
you've seen this before is are these
Postcards From the world exhibition in
1900 and these show how people imagine
the year 2000 and I think it's like
they're more of these um I love looking
at them it's like super interesting and
what you can really see here is that
like yes people try to solve problems
that we have also solved but also in
inherently human shape ways or by
solving they directly solving the way
these things were dealt with before like
this like scrubbing robot or like this
very physics defying flying
um firefighter force that like I don't
know does not consider water pressure
but
um you know we have solved
um all of these things and um some of
them actually you know actually the this
Vision there for video
um calls was actually relatively
accurate but
um we also went a step further and we
didn't just take the problem and
translated it one to one into
um you know a technical solution
especially you know for the firefighting
yes we might have um you know built
better fire trucks but we also built
smoke alarms and we even built
um yeah we use better materials to build
buildings that are not wood to prevent
these fires in the first place so
um you know it goes a lot further than
that and
um similarly you know even if we're
looking at like you know computers and
Technology replacing human labor
um one thing we see here is yeah we have
a whole room of people adding adding up
things and calculating sums and we can
replace all of that with a calculator
and again also one of my absolute
favorites
um up to the 1950s
the drop of a knocker upper existed and
those were people hired with to walk
around with a stick knock on people's
windows so they would wake up in time
for work when alarm clocks weren't
reliable enough and
um you know yes we have replaced this
with technology with better alarm clocks
with phones that we now have in our
pockets but I think this is also a great
example we did not replace
with a window knocking machine and I
think this is always a very important
test if you're thinking about like hey
how can I use technology to solve a
problem am I building the alarm clock
and really solving the problem in the
most efficient way for the human or am I
building a window knocking machine that
literally translates what a human does
um into technology and we can actually
see an example of this in
um yeah the not the
more recent past
um in the first kind of chatbot hype
where people imagined hey we can finally
build something that kind of works let's
try and mimic exactly what a human does
and translate that into a chatbot so you
can talk to a bot
um to book your meetings and a lot of
that didn't work so well
um because it turned out that there are
actually much better ways to use
technology to solve that problem and one
of those is calendly which I love for
scheduling you send someone a link and
they can book something that's much
better than talking to a bot version of
a human going back and forth on time
zones or even using NLP and using
language understanding in a slightly
different way by say letting you write
natural language descriptions of your
appointments that are then automatically
added to your calendar and
I think we also have a similar questions
question or similar questions that we
have to ask ourselves when we look at
hey we have these large models that can
do pretty impressive things and really
add a lot of new capabilities what does
that mean how will the future look like
and what's kind of the equivalent of say
a window knocking Machine versus an
alarm clock
and when we look at NLP natural language
processing in the age of large language
models like gpt4 chat GPT they're kind
of two different they're they're kind of
off in a lot of ways polar Visions
um of how um you know the future could
look and one of those is
um on this spectrum of on the one side
structured data is still going to be
really important
um SQL whatever databases that's all you
need
um and that's going to kind of stay that
way and on the other end you have a take
that's more like hey dialogue is all you
need all
um problems are going to be you know
solved by talking to a bot in a dialogue
form and we kind of we can cut out the
whole database thing all together and
similarly on another axis
um we have the um you know the on end of
the spectrum well we still need a lot of
humans that can create data that can
work with the system
um and you know really build these
applications and on the other end you
have a take that we also sometimes see
that's well ultimately it's all going to
be about prompting
um that's
um you know the future you know is yeah
we prompt a model we're not going to
actually interact with it in any other
way and those are those are kind of the
questions and
one given that we've we've talked about
in our generative and predictive tasks
here I wanted to show you like a very
classic NLP problem that we see all the
time that comes up in pretty much any
industry and that's also something kind
of fundamental that like us humans we've
done before computers manually and then
we've been doing it with computers and
now we're trying to do it with better
and better machine learning models and
that's extracting structured data from
unstructured text so you know here we
have a text about a fundraising
announcement and of course these come in
in any kind of natural language and what
we want to find out is who invested in
which company how much money and so on
put that in a database so we can later
calculate stuff so ultimately what we
really have to do here is we have to
first we have to extract these companies
we have to disambiguate them so like map
them to an entry in a knowledge base
make sure that it's that Apple that Holy
um and so on that we're talking about we
need to look it up in some custom
database like whether it's crunch base
or some internal thing that like we've
been curating for decades and also
currency we need to extract that after
we've extracted that we need to
normalize that into like an integer that
we can do maths with and we also need to
extract relations so that's you know a
very classic problem and there are
different ways to solve that like you
know there is you know you can sometimes
do some of these things quite well by
just prompting a large language model
you can build it the old school way
but this is really um the thing that
we're trying to solve and if we can do
that better that's kind of one of the
things that has the biggest
value in like a lot of real world
applications
and you know we're going back here we're
kind of strongly we're on the predictive
side and
um one thing you know we can
um see here is well we can you know take
something like gpt4 out of the box ask
it
um to give us all of that information
then it gives us back text because you
know it's genitive
um they're going back
um you know trying to extract all the
information out of it that works quite
well but also what if you know what if
we kind of want more of this and also
given that this is kind of my
terminology slide as well don't have to
specifically on the slide but I think
one other important distinction is what
are we even calling a large language
model like unfortunately right
especially at the moment the terminology
in I don't know the fields in J or in
the world in general is incredibly vague
and there's also you know some PR speak
involved and you know this so you can
you find people calling every fine-tuned
bird model that companies have had in
production for like years a large
language model now which is maybe
technically correct but also technically
not so there is like um you know there
is this um distinction here I'm mostly
using llm to mean like
um a model that does in context learning
and I'm getting to that later but um you
know we're not talking about stuff we've
already had
um you know for you know a long time but
one thing that's actually kind of
interesting and surprising is that um
at the moment
um Out of the Box large language models
don't necessarily do that well on
structured prediction tasks at least not
as well as you might think so here are
some
um you know benchmarks we ran and you
can see you know the accuracy of and the
accuracy on you know the percent of
examples that we use so we basically you
know compared uh what if we train like a
bird sized model and compare that
against like um you know just the zero
shot output that we get and
um first one we did there was a
sentiment data set that's a really
relatively easy problem
um you know predicting sentiment and
here what we can see is well you know
almost 95 out of the box that's really
good it's a simple problem and here
still we do need to use 50 of the
examples that we have if we're really
training a model on labeled examples
where we know the answer to get to that
Baseline but again it's still you know
we can still beat that with only you
know fifty percent
um of the training set
so next one is slightly harder but still
pretty standard uh news data set
predicting categories over news and
um here we see that actually the
Baseline starts pretty low I mean 85
pretty good
um we wouldn't have been able to do that
so easily years ago but even with one
percent of the training data we can beat
That by five percent so if we just take
one percent off labeled examples trainer
model with it we have something that's
much smaller and um also much faster
private and better so that was like
pretty exciting so it's like okay can we
do this even more and here's an even
harder data set which is about banking
so lots of specific terminology Baseline
still again 70 is not bad but um it's
also quite low we want better than that
and here again with
um you know even you know with five
percent of examples uh we can beat that
significantly and it even keeps going up
so if we we use the whole training set
or even just 50 of it we can get
significantly better accuracy so that's
all pretty motivating so you know if we
really if we know exactly what we're
trying to do like predict categories we
can um you know we can build something
uh that's better
pretty easily and um another nice
example here is um this is on named
entity recognition so extracting spans
of texts like person organization from
um unstructured
um data so here we what we could see is
that that's the current state of yacht
unless
um you know something came up recently
which I don't think it did so this is um
you know on few short prompting if we
just take gpd4 GPT 3.5
we get pretty good accuracy out of the
box on this Benchmark data set
um also you know still lower than you
know what's out there and easy to use
and also still lower interestingly then
the state of the art in 2003 which is
when that data set was released and
granted this is just like this is one
um you know benchmark data set that's
not even that great and also we
shouldn't discount the big Advantage
here is that like hey we can get to 83
percent accuracy
without doing anything but we can also
get much higher and I think that's kind
of where um you know the interesting
part is if we can get um you know a lot
of nice things out of the box
um how how much further can we bring
this and again here
um the important distinction whether we
call it llm or however we call it is
that these large models they use in
context learning so it they know a lot
and a lot about what the text means but
they don't really know what you wanted
to do which is um you know which makes a
lot of sense and then on the other side
we have what I'm calling task specific
models which for some reason also some
people call llms which makes the whole
thing really confusing
um and here we're really talking about
fine tuning something like Bert for a
very specific task if we know what we
want we can yeah take advantage of that
so here a model obviously knows less a
lot less about what the text means
because it's smaller but we can use to
Advantage that we could encode exactly
what we wanted to do in the model and
that means that we can actually use this
during development and we can take this
large language model take everything
that's in it that's good and useful and
then use that to develop a task-specific
model that has a lot of advantages it's
smaller faster better and you know we
can really as we've seen even on some
pretty basic experiments we can beat the
accuracy and I'm sure with better larger
language models and better techniques we
can take this even further and make this
even more efficient so what we as the
developer have to do here is prompt
engineering we have to still think about
how do we Define the problem that's not
um you know that's not going to go away
magically if you know we still have to
decide what we even want to do and why
and how we have to create some data we
can use the large language model to do
that but we still have to you know make
sure that our data is good because
otherwise we can't fine tune a model
that's like this code and we of course
need to train it and evaluate it
evaluation we need to do in any case
because we need to know
um how good our system is and if it
improves and you know it's easy to have
a system that's 100 accurate if your
evaluation is straight but that's like
that's not the point we want to build
something that's actually good
and then this task specific model is
something we can actually ship to
production and it's something we own
once maybe is can be under one gigabyte
and it just can run fast efficient as
we've also seen previously in a
benchmarks any task specific model will
be significantly faster than any API we
don't have to worry about latency we can
just ship it
and so what I'm basically saying is if
we go back to our
um axes here
um I see modern practical NLP pretty
much in the middle of this
um we still want structured data there
are a lot of use cases and problems
where you know kind of replacing that
with the dialogue would be the
equivalent of a window knocking machine
like we still structured data has its
place and it's good for a lot of things
we still need humans in the loop we need
high quality data we need to evaluate
whether what we're doing makes sense and
has the right purpose and often the end
consumer of this are human so we need
and subject matter experts who can
actually validate what we're doing but
the prompting and dialogue based
genitive models do give us very fast
prototyping so we instead of having to
collect hundreds of examples
um or putting in 40 hours before we get
kind of a model we can improve we
can now start off with like a pretty
decent or even kind of model that
we can improve and use
um you know the llms or the the
prompting at development time to build a
system that's even better than what we
could do before and I also think it's
going to be powered by open source of
course on the cold side but also a lot
of the work and especially in Academia
is also still happening in the comments
and it's public and I do think open
source Technologies open source tooling
and of course python will play a big
role in that and we also need a mix of
conversational and graphical interfaces
like just because you can talk to this
model and in a conversational style
doesn't mean that a conversational UI is
like the best solution for everything
again uh window knocking machines versus
um alarm clocks so in a lot of cases a
graphical UI where you can click a
button or select a meeting you want to
book or do whatever if you're an analyst
looking at a list of things you could
filter is better than having to talk to
a bot so I think yeah none of this
graphical interfaces are not going away
and that means we also need structured
data and
um yeah we need to approach this in a
more holistic way
so in practice I'll give you like a very
quick I know um yeah I'm already I've
started late so of course I'm late
um but I want to give you a little
example of what this looks like in
practice what you can already use now
um and also of course a little snapshot
of what we've been developing so what we
really see as incredibly important in
this is a large language model powered
collaborative data development platform
and environment that
um you could developers can work on
subject matter experts can work on and
where you can use the LMS to create
label data that you can then use to
train better models and that means if
you want to train these better task
specific models that data needs to be
good transfer learning has this great
advantage that we can train really good
models with good embeddings and very few
examples but that actually makes these
very few examples more valuable not less
so these need to be really good but with
good tooling we can do that and we also
want to tune prompts and compare the
models in an empirical way and there's
like a lot of cool work happening
um in that we also have been doing some
of that internally like a lot of it a
lot of the things people do are mostly
trial and error and just like trying
something out and saying hmm this this
feels slightly better but you know you
want to have an easy way to just see
what works best
and
um with all of that you can build data
sets and actually train and also
evaluate more efficient production-ready
pipelines that really solve the problem
that you have and come
um with all the other advantages
so here's an example
um actually of some of the workflows
we've built in our annotation tool
Prodigy but something similar
um you know works even you know if you
can even build something like that
yourself on the command line in just
Python and what we're doing here is we
ask the openai API
for predictions on this text given these
labels and then we highlight those spans
in the text all the model has seen are
like other labels
now also optional label descriptions and
the text and then it tries to give us
these fans what we can see is there are
some mistakes it will always inevitably
make mistakes especially it can be quite
inconsistent and also non-deterministic
so you know you might do the same thing
tomorrow and it gives you different
predictions which kind of sucks but you
can correct these mistakes
yeah and submit it so that's all very
easy and you can also add correct
answers to the prompt to tune it if you
have like specific things where you feel
like hey um the model keeps making
mistakes so it's something weird in my
domain you can include it in the prompt
and hopefully get better predictions or
not and then you kind of have to go back
and include more examples
and um under the hood there the kind of
one of the hard Parts is that a
generative model is genitive and so the
output is text so we feed it a text and
we want structure data out of it but
what it gives us back is a text so
there's actually a lot of work going
into like how can we write better
prompts to achieve that and make it
output something that like then lets us
turn it back into
structured
annotations on the data because again it
will just reply with this string
location colon London Berlin and then we
kind of have to go and map that back in
the text so we can say hey this
character to this character that's what
we're interested in because we really
want to we want to usually map it back
into our original data and for that we
have built an extension to space c which
is called Spacey llm and it does take
care of all of that the prompting under
the hood in a way it works quite
similarly to what Spacey does if you've
used it before because our vision has
always been we want to build one named
entity recognition component that just
works and does the thing you don't have
to choose between lots of algorithms it
just works and here we kind of trying to
do the same thing with the prompting and
what you get back is a dock object that
works just like
any other Spacey dog object whether you
use a machine learning model whether you
use rules or whether you use any large
language model whether it's an API but
also a open source model you host
yourself someone else hosts under the
host so you can easily swap that out and
compare the results as well evaluate get
a score know what you what Baseline you
have to beat and then take it from there
and so yep currently these are
components that we have including really
cool stuff that actually was a lot
harder to do previously with just the
machine learning model like relation
extraction
that can work quite well so we've been
trying this out and that's actually
quite exciting but also even for more
classic
um you know linguistic tasks like
limitization that's also still
incredibly important in a lot of
applications not as sexy as a lot of
other things but um still pretty
important and you can use
um under the horde
either a large language Model A
supervised model or rules and you can
mix and match these as well in a
pipeline so you can have one component
powered by that one component powered by
that and that's kind of the concept of
it and we've yeah it's under very active
development we've been continuously
adding features and we think this could
really you know be a big part in that
Vision that we have that allows people
to build these kind of superior models
basically
so to wrap this up and have barbecue
um my main point that I'm trying to make
here is that easier isn't ambitious
enough yes a lot of advantages of just
writing a prompt are that it's easy and
helps people get started and that's
really that's great and I think this
will have a huge positive impact on our
field but we also want to think Beyond
just hey let's put some API in in our
system and call it a day we don't want
to build stuff that's actually worse
than what we're currently building and
the quality of the systems the machine
learning systems that are in production
today is high and you know we shouldn't
underestimate that so we don't want to
build systems and things that are worse
just because oh it's a bit easier or
maybe it's a bit cheaper or maybe not so
I'm my um you know
my main
um goal or my main message is people
ambitious and that's because well often
being specific is better if you know
what you want you can build systems that
do exactly what you
um want to do and
um last time I gave a talk or this talk
in a slightly modified version I got a
question asking me about like Skynet and
like oh apocalypse and like oh if I
believe in like machines taking over and
the whole Doom argument and actually
even aside from anything I said in this
talk today if if you are worried about
like all the Duma outcomes this is you
should also care about this because if
you train a task specific fine-tuned
bird this is never going to take over
the world like this is going to predict
at one out of five labels and no matter
what you give it it's never gonna be
able to do something evil like I'm not a
Doomer but like if you meet Dumas this
is also uh the message for you
and also
um smaller and faster is better there's
so many you know we don't need to run if
like we've have good systems in
production we don't need to replace them
with like an API that runs at what 100
words per second like there are a lot of
cases where we want something small and
we want something fast and we want
something that we can maybe run on a
phone on a one single GPU on your laptop
even if it's not the latest M2 MacBook
and there's absolutely a case for that
and why would we not do that if we can
like if we can make models bigger we can
also make them smaller while making them
just as good and much better at the same
at the very specific task that we know
we want
and private is also better like we don't
have to send our data to some random API
in some random country or some random
startup and we shouldn't have to do have
to settle for that we can run things
ourselves whether you know we care about
data privacy
um whether we're forced to do this by
law or not
um you know private data privacy is good
and um you know I think that's another
great advantage
and finally better is always better like
we want to train systems that are better
than what we have not worse there are a
lot of cases where um you know it's
always going to be a race to the top we
don't want the fraud detection system
that's like surprisingly good given it
hasn't been trained like it needs to be
like really good and better than
anything else and there are tons of
these use cases so I think we should aim
higher
um than just mer it's um you know pretty
good and convenient and I think there's
a lot to be done there's also
um a lot we're working on and I think we
can be more ambitious and yeah I'm very
excited to see what the future holds
thanks
[Applause]
let's run on switch one
test us yes
all right we do have a few minutes for
questions only of you because barbecue
is waiting already but we can do
barbecue and people can I don't want to
want people to sit here like we'll do a
quick one okay okay so you can ask a
question on slido or here in the room if
you want to ask a question in the room
just raise your hand and I'll forward
you the microphone and I'll do my best
with my climbing abilities there okay
any question in the room okay there's
one could you father straight in the
back
hey thank you for the nice talk
um you showed a prompt that make
give you lines of the named entities
yeah but you yeah you could maybe also
have told it hey give me a Json
structured output and give me also all
the structured data that I want I assume
you tried that and it's not great but do
you think it will always not be great
yeah so this is a good question also
um it reminded me that the prompt I have
on this slide is sort of the bad Pro
like not the best prompt not the current
prompt because we have actually so in
the latest version of Spacey we
implemented let me go through here ah I
almost had it sorry
wait where's my uh yeah here uh that um
paper which is the state of the art on
future prompting and that implements a
technique that is better than pretty
much anything else people have fight for
ner and that's what we're implementing I
think it's not it's not the Json
um way of doing it and I do think they
are like there are some cases where the
Json works but also in our case there
are a lot of
like we don't need to predict like the
whole structure like there's a lot we
can infer once we kind of know where to
align it in the text so
um I don't exactly like know all the
things we've tried but like basically
what we have implemented now is
something that's better
um and yeah you can so there's a
reference to the paper here it's also in
Spacey llm I can look at this later and
then maybe give you some more background
on that but yeah that's this is like
it's all this is kind of the prompt
engineering
like magic like stuff that everyone's
playing around with and it's actually
people presented like it's it's science
when actually I think a lot of it it's
just like man we don't we all don't
really know what's going on and people
are just trying
all right so questions on slido are more
targeted to the panel later so maybe
another question in the room and then
we'll go for barbecue
maybe I shouldn't have said that sorry
but uh is there another question
yeah
um a question about another layer of
entity recognition so to say to
differentiate a relation for example as
absurd or fictitious or factual is there
something that you think is going to in
the diet Direction
um with the use for example of knowledge
graphs or because you are not really
building some kind of information uh
relations between different entities
that you can actually go to
um to a database and check okay is this
factual or this fictitious or is this
actually absurd
um yeah so that's a that's a good
question and actually that also I
brought up this slide because it kind of
ties into this pipeline design and
really the problem the the problem of
hey I have this thing which I want how
do I break it down into something that
works best and I think one option it
sounds like knowledge base entity
linking
um something like that sounds like that
is for example a component you can add
so even if you do ner with like the llm
Spacey for example has a knowledge base
component that you can plug in you can
also you know write something custom and
then there's an interesting question if
you have like mentions that you extract
as spans is that you could Benchmark
that against an approach where you
actually just do it simpler as a text
classification task so you're like given
this sentence with these entity mentions
are these observed or something and that
is like that's kind of a classic
reimagining or breaking the task down
into something that's potentially easier
and that's kind of the thing you need to
try out and that's also where we come in
and say hey if you have if we we try to
build tools that make this easier and
make it easier to experiment and try out
these different approaches and I was
thinking so the use case would be
typically your if you're in a company
you have a customer and then he writes
you something and maybe you need your
your model or your your recommendation
to actually give better better
recommendation but you need to actually
to ask further because maybe the the
customer didn't understand exactly what
he was expressing in terms of business
language for example he would have
what's the problem I didn't understand
this problem because actually we are
maybe I'm confused maybe it's this thing
yeah or you could you could use maybe
maybe if you have depending on what you
predict if that gives you confidence
goals and you want to be extra sure you
could say like okay if my model gives me
less than 80 percent I need to ask the
user to rephrase or I could use a
generative model to rephrase it ask the
user back like is this what you meant
and then the user can say yes or no or
like there are a lot of these
combinations but again also I think
that's where like oh you still need to
break down the problem and like
reason about reason about the different
flows yeah
thank you
all right so Ines will be around for the
barbecue and I'm sure she will take all
your questions there and also she will
be around for the pedal later right yeah
so um
I suggest we go for barbecue now and to
those watching remotely see you later
we're about half an hour delayed so
we'll start about half an hour later
sorry it's my fault
[Applause]